I'm Jay Pharoah and I'm here to answer
the internet who would be the world's
most dominant 101 basketball player if
everyone was forced to play naked
Jesus I only want to say this
[Laughter]
oh my gosh who uh let's see here Dwight
Howard
all right
debate I'm not gonna explain why I said
that look it up for yourself would you
rather have your internet history made
public or a sex tape that goes viral oh
I either one I'm fine uh okay next
if you can put any franchise restaurant
in your house what would it be oh my
gosh what is my favorite freaking
restaurant guys why is this place called
love bake Wings in L.A and I would have
five of those downstairs
Perpetual Wings all day what's like your
favorite sauce my favorite oh uh Memphis
uh Memphis hot that's my favorite yeah
I'm a spice I don't know if y'all know
this about me
I drink hot sauce
that I have and guess what it doesn't
affect me yeah back in the day I built
up a real high Scotia level yeah not a
part it was more church I was like yeah
it was a party trick I said yo hey y'all
y'all want to see something like yeah I
said okay cool I'm gonna drink
everything every bottle of hot sauce
that's on these tables in this cafeteria
we had a cafeteria now and I drank
everything paid for it about 15-20
minutes later yeah man did they give you
it was hot I did you haven't you haven't
heard y'all need to I have one of the
best I dominated this [__] I was one of
the people that got through everything
with no problems yeah I'm I'm a freak
bro
Ortega did that recently too watch Jay
Pharoah hot ones 20 2016. in 2019 I
killed it too but 2016 was the first one
that's great nothing like the first time
what would you pick to be the title of
your autobiography Jesus these are some
deep questions
um
Jared Bale
that's my real name and uh it's highly
Caucasian I was gonna say you said Jared
I thought Subway I was like what oh yeah
imagine being 12 years old and him being
the hottest thing and your name is Jared
and you're a big kid oh boy they will
walk by me and say subway I was like oh
I hate it here if you could only watch
one actors movies for the rest of your
life who would it be Denzel Washington
easy bam why didn't I say Eddie Murphy I
don't know he's just second but Denzel
he's the top one who would win in the
fight Allen Iverson or Yao Ming oh I
gotta go with Allen Iverson baby he's
from Newport News uh Newport News which
is in Virginia as you know have you seen
Yao Ming though like post post
basketball life I think he's like 400
pounds yeah yeah but he's not even fat
he's just like he's talking and he's
never he's like the size of this wall
yeah I mean doesn't have to fight look
you would Allen Iverson had to fight
yeah I know this for sure I'm telling
you Newport News is the nickname for it
is bad news it is bad news the little
kid shot the teacher there oh yeah yeah
no [__] a bad year listen we go hard
we're all programs Allen Iverson
if you can live anyone's life in their
body who would you be God Jack it why
would you ask me that
if you could live anyone's life in their
body who would you be I mean you can
already do their voice so now you got to
pick their body
Dwayne Johnson yes jabroni I just gotta
I've got to do it would you rather have
sex with two midgets or two seven foot
tall girls
uh I I don't get intimidated by height
so um bring on the tall bring on the
Avatar Jones
they like me too Pat me on top of my
head shut up stop doing that you make me
feel like a toddler
waffles are pancakes pancakes not a
question damn right okay I just look if
I go to the Waffle House I'm not there
to eat I'm there to watch
bro
I saw a video it was a dude and he was
at a waffle house and he was eating his
cheese grits and a fight just started
breaking out behind him he just goes
like this he goes he goes
I saw a tweet like that once it was like
Waffle House doesn't have job
applications they just make you square
up
can you scratch cause you're gonna need
it forget about your culinary skills
would you rather relive your best sports
moments or your best sex moments [__]
sex Sports you don't have anything
Sports too I got one player I didn't
even score I still remember it I was so
true I was not like I was bad I learned
but I didn't I had add so getting me to
pay attention to yeah the football or
something it was hard yeah so I you know
I figured it out later yeah yeah but the
ladies though I always pay attention
would you rather have your porn search
history shared with your Twitter
followers or your parents my parents
yeah because they're not going to judge
me and uh if I'm a freak it's because of
y'all
please subscribe to the channel comment
below on other celebrities you'd like to
see and make sure you hit the Bell to
get notifications when new episodes come
out